welcome to another
the week in 60 minutes from spectator tv
recorded
in london on thursday october the 29th
on this week's show i'll be speaking to
spectator editor fraser nelson
about advice the british government has
been getting
from its scientists on the scale of
covered second wave
i'll also be getting the thoughts of
professor jay batachira
from stanford university in california
one of the authors of the great
barrington declaration we'll speak to
jonathan miller our man in france
after yet another terrorist attack today
this time in nice
where three were killed by a jihadist
armed with a knife
including an elderly woman the
spectator's home team will update on the
latest in uk politics and rod little
will be telling me why he thinks
marcus rashford should not be getting
his way
when it comes to free school meals
during the holidays
and with only five days to go till
election day in america our u.s editor
freddie gray will join us from the
campaign trail
speaking of the u.s election if you
think you know who's going to win
and it's a 50 50 chance you could get a
30 pound
amazon gift voucher go to spectator dot
co dot uk
slash president to subscribe for just
one pound a week
to the spectator select the man you
think will be the next president
and if you get it right a 30 pound
amazon gift voucher will be on
its way to you can't do better than that
a special thanks to charles stanley for
supporting this episode of the week in
60 minutes
charles stanley is one of the uk's
leading wealth management firms
one of the oldest companies on the
london stock exchange
first will the second wave of the
pandemic be even worse
than the first the papers this morning
are full of speculation based on
modeling by the scientific
advisory group for emergencies also
known
as sage fraser nelson has actually seen
the documents
and reveals all in this week's exclusive
cover story
fraser over to you thank you andrew well
this is a document that we didn't know
existed let alone we didn't know the
contents of it which is quite strange
because it's probably the most important
of the sage documents sage of the
scientific advisory committee
to the government and they drew up a
reasonable worst case
scenario this isn't a prediction it's
what is a grim
outlook but importantly it's what the
cabinet office says the government
should plan
around now this is why it's rather
important that we know
what assumptions are being made and how
long it involves but for some reason
it's been kept secret while sage has
been publishing
other documents now we got a hold of it
ours is dated at the end of july
but i'll show you just what it says so
this is the death
so far the deaths um are going down
and mrs sage came up with this document
at the end of july so it looked as if
the first wave was almost over
sage said back then well we expect it to
stay low
but in november it's going to pick up
it's going to rise fast in january
it's going to peak around the end of
february and start its descent
in march now that was a pretty bleak
forecast and but nonetheless that is is
what they said now let's look at what
actually happened
it's certainly true that death stayed
low throughout the summer
then they started their rise they
started them as you will see
a good six or seven weeks earlier than
this age scenario
and when death started to rise they
started just as quickly
as sage predicted now you can imagine
the conversations inside downing street
right now the sage committee that had
asked boris johnson to implement a
circuit breaker a few weeks ago
will be telling him look this is exactly
as we predicted except it's happened
even earlier
and our um forecasts show it will kill
even more
now if you have a look at those two
graphs there you can see that the second
peak
is only about 800 deaths versus more
than a thousand at the first peak but
then
if you have a look at the areas of this
graph that's what matters how many
people
would how many lives would be taken in
the first it was forty thousand
in the second eighty five thousand that
eighty five thousand is actually an
underestimate because the sage
forecast only goes to the end of march
so there will be more to follow after
that
now whether you think this is too bleak
or
not bleak enough the important thing is
this is a scenario that the government
will be working on or certainly
a variant of that scenario and the same
is true with hospital admissions they've
already started to rise
and quite quickly and exactly the speed
that sage
expected they would back in the summer
so if you're on the sage committee right
now you're thinking yes
we were right uh the government was
doing a bit too much wishful thinking so
now
they had better listen to us so
that's because there could be 350 000
nhs
admissions in the next second wave
that's according to sage
versus only 135 000 admissions so far
so this is the this is why the prime
minister
has been talking in private um about a
second wave that's even bigger than the
first
those are the figures being shown to him
and it's quite
um it's quite depressing really to think
that we are now in
for a pretty long winter
fraser this document must now be
informing
the prime minister's thinking and if it
is informing his thinking
the country's heading for a lockdown is
it not
um that's at the moment i would say more
likely than not we have to remember that
he was talking to emmanuel macron only a
couple of weeks ago and macron was
saying to him
look prime minister britain and france
can't do national lock lines again
local lockdowns are the way to go they
agreed on that
then he switches on his tv and sees that
macron has decided no the virus is
growing
far too fast so we need to do national
lockdown when you've got germany going
the same way
the pressure on him to follow suit will
be pretty big
right now and also if he's going to
argue against sage and what
basis does he do that because right now
you see that sage
spy m the joint biosecurity committee
these are groups which all advise them
but they only look at the epidemic
there isn't an equivalent of sage
looking at the broader public health
implications
there's no group modeling mental health
cancer deaths and
all the other things that come from
people who should be being treated by
the medical system
aren't going to be treated you only see
one side of this equation
that's distinct from sweden whose public
health agency the clue is in the name
they look at all public health and they
judged only this time last week
that it was time to abolish advice for
the over 70s and encourage them to move
back into society
because the risk of isolation and
loneliness was greater than the threat
from the virus that's a balancing act
which isn't really
being done under the british system
where you've got people looking only at
the epidemic
and asking the government to make a
decision
there's been some skepticism of sage
predictions or
scenarios as they call them in the past
but when you look at this one the one
that you revealed in the spectator cover
story uh today
uh and it was done back at the end of
july
if you look at what's actually happened
this one's looking
pretty accurate or if anything a worst
case
scenario which has underestimated the
rise in cases
that's the big difference i mean at the
beginning of march the worst case
scenarios being churned out
were quite depressing the modelers were
telling the nhs for example to prepare
for two million people
in the end they had less than a tenth of
that figure
so some of the health authorities are
thinking well i'm not quite sure
how much we can rely on these scenarios
because the error margins once you move
more than two weeks away into the
horizon are pretty big
so should we really be reordering the
nhs expecting
a deluge in 5 000 people in intensive
care
but so far anyway the models have proved
cannily
and accurate and that's why i think the
debate this time around
really will be different boris johnson
did want to buy time
he did only to find out that sage seemed
so far
to have been proved right at an earlier
stage than even they
feared would happen thanks let's bring
in professor
gianta batacharya he's an epidemiologist
and public health
expert at the university of stamford in
california
his research focuses on the health of
vulnerable populations
he co-authored the great barrington
declaration along with oxford's
sunitra gupta who we had on the show
just a few weeks ago
it's advocating a different way to deal
with the pandemic it's not
keen on lockdowns he has a new article
published online
in the spectator website today professor
welcome
to spectator tv it seems
that governments cannot resist lockdowns
that mr macron
set his face against one but he's doing
it
mr johnson set his face against one we
expect him to do it too
why do you think that is well it's it's
really tempting because you think that
we can control the spread of the virus
with this general lockdown
but lockdowns have proven not to be very
effective
in controlling the spread i mean uk had
a lockdown
general lockdown earlier this year and
yet the virus continued to spread
argentina has had a lockdown yet the
virus continues to spread but
we've seen sort of the failure of
lockdowns everywhere what's what we need
are new ideas for
containing the damage of the virus
rather than to try to contain the
general spread of the virus
which has proved to be a poor strategy
one
reason for the original lockdown was the
capacity of our health systems would
they be overwhelmed let's try
and spread it out a bit so they weren't
that would still seem to be a problem
though president macron said last night
that there would soon be 9 000
covert patients needing intensive care
in france that it was a danger of
swamping the system that is a reason for
a lockdown is it not
it might be a better approach would be
to expand capacity
locally when it's necessary right so
build field hospitals and other
other facilities that can address the
overflow should be there i mean i think
it's very important to note that
uh the the the cues for other services
get delayed extensively as a result of
these kinds of uh these sort of
attempts to reduce this the the pressure
on
hospital assistance and anticipation in
many many parts of the country for
instance the united states
during the general lockdown in in march
and april uh the hospitals ran empty
and people who had needed cancer
services or or other services
basically delayed care i think the
similar things have happened in the uk
and france basically everywhere where
our locker has happened there are a few
concentrated places where
at risk of being overrun with kobe cases
and most of the rest of the country end
up uh hospitals empty that don't serve
patients that
that die from other causes so i think a
better approach is a
is a is to have an expansion of capacity
locally use use methods to move patients
uh to places where there's less
you know less pressure those are smarter
approaches but can you
expand intensive care quickly
the technology is complicated the
training can take years and years can
you really just
ramp it up in response to horizon cases
well i mean
the question is like how much do you
need of it right so i think i think the
answer is yes i mean i think we've seen
uh in many places uh the the uh
expertise in managing patients has grown
substantially uh you can
use paper physicians who are uh they may
not be always in intensive care
but that but they have some training
there's a lot of creative ways to
address
this kind of constraint
you talk about focused protection
instead of a lockdown the lockdown
you think is a bit of a sledgehammer
focused protection
what do you mean by that so it's very
it's very simple
in one sense we know that the virus is
much more deadly for
older people and people with a few
chronic conditions
we should do everything we possibly can
to help them so for instance
nursing homes are absolutely the the
deadliest places to be
when you don't have focus protection we
should use our testing resources and
other
ingenuity to protect people living in
care homes
uh because that's where the the virus
ends up killing
um on the other hand as on the other
hand like with the lockdown we ask
older workers who are potentially
vulnerable to the disease to go back
into the workforce
because they're essential and expose
themselves to the virus the lockdown
doesn't protect them
um so i think use use our our welfare
systems
uh and you know disability accommodation
laws so that we
can provide support for those workers so
they don't have to go
you know get be exposed to the virus uh
the lockdown actually creates
multi-generational homes
right young adults move back in with
older parents exposing the parents
because the economic harm from the
lockdown um the universities sometimes
get closed
uh so you you end up actually creating
more depth than you would expect
as a result of the lockdown you need
much more creative ways of dealing with
this
same time younger populations the harm
from covid is less
than the harm from the lockdowns
themselves the psychological harm the
physical harm
and other harms on net we're asking uh
with the general lockdown for a younger
population to
essentially accept this harm even though
it hasn't actually helped suppress the
diamonds from the virus the focus
protection is
let's take advantage of what we know
about the virus and design an
intelligence strategy
as opposed to a sledgehammer to deal
with it so if we focus protection
on the older the more vulnerable those
with underlying conditions that could
make them
susceptible to covert how would we
do that if we we wouldn't want young
people to visit the older people or
younger families or even their
grown-up kids to visit them who looks
after them
if they their family can't go and see
them
no andrew that's a really important
question and i think um
for instance we can use these new rapid
tests so if you're
going to go visit your uh your uh parent
in a nursing home you take a rapid test
if you're negative then you can you go
if you're positive now you would this
would be a personal decision so if it's
your your older parent is feeling lonely
uh you have to
make a quick decision about what whether
to go you have to balance that against
the potential harm from
spreading covet each person is would be
in a better position than in a general
dictat that says oh no no you can't go
uh you have to stay within two miles
like the lockdown in in victoria for
instance australia was
you couldn't even travel very far
outside of your home um i mean these
kinds of things are much more isolating
versus a focused protection approach
which allows each person to make
decisions based on accurate information
um and resources that are poured into
helping make them make those decisions
as a
i mean i think a blunderbuss approach as
we've seen has not
worked and causes enormous harm
in other things other than coving we
should be thinking about public health
from a more holistic point of view
uh and i think we'll do better with both
covet and non-cove
sort of sources of harm from public
health the goal should be public
flourishing not a human flourishing not
simply
infection control the scientific
community seems to be pretty divided on
this you had plenty of people
signing your declaration distinguished
scientists doing so
yet anthony fauci in the united states
he called it quote total nonsense
and the wh so the world health
organization said
it's scientifically and ethically
problematic
it's hard for the rest of us when the
top experts can't agree
i mean it's unfortunately but that's the
case that there are a lot of
disagreement in the scientific community
over this
uh i'd ask you to look at the record of
lockdowns the the record of the
lockdowns in the united states has been
terrible we've had 220 000 deaths
many of which were out on were avoidable
and almost 100 000 excess deaths above
and beyond that from non-coveted sources
that which will continue to grow in the
future as as the harm from
skipping cancer treatments and other
other kinds of things that that got lost
the psychological harm of people with uh
one in four young adults seriously
considering suicide just this past june
in the united states
i don't think that's uncommon i think
that's typical of the rest of the world
lockdowns are not a way for people to
live
and they will have enormous harm in
coming years i think
that assessment will start to move in
our direction very very
soon as we start to see the mounting
harms from the lockdown
i thought that these excess death
figures you mentioned uh professor in
the united states i thought were
interesting
so the cdc says 300 000
excess deaths over what you'd normally
expect on the five-year average
up 200 000 they had related to covert
but a hundred thousand not related to
covert
but in some way probably related to
covert in the sense that
you couldn't get the cancer treatment
you couldn't be treated for depression
or stress and so on is that correct
yeah but i mean i wouldn't call it
covert i would call that lockdown that's
those are lockdown deaths
is what those are you can contrast that
with sweden 6 thousand cove does this
thing on the order six thousand sweeps i
if i'm if i have the shaker correct
uh where only two thousand on the order
of two thousand excess deaths
fewer excess deaths than coveted deaths
in sweden to date
um they've minimized the non-excess
deaths
that the non-coveted deaths the lockdown
deaths
and actually i think saved lives as a
consequence i think we should be
thinking in that way we shouldn't just
be looking at
covet cases and say okay we failed or
succeeded we should be thinking about
public health generally and decide if we
fail to succeed
professor is it uh your fear
that we've been in one lockdown with him
we came out
we by the way i mean europe parts of the
united states too go into another
lockdown
that it's it's a kind of hokey cokey
lockdown we're doing it
in out in out is that the danger
of the current consensus that is exactly
the danger andrew and i think that that
is where we're headed if we keep
if we don't look for alternatives uh you
know i know france is locked down as
fraser said i think germany is
considered or maybe maybe they've
already decided
i think this sort of policy myopia is a
mistake
uh there are better alternatives
available alternatives that actually
have
succeeded uh not it's not just
theoretical alternatives
uh and we should adopt those because it
would it would uh it would result in
both
better covet outcomes and non-coded
outcomes the lockdowns don't protect the
vulnerable we've seen that
uh and if we adopt another lockdown
again again the vulnerable will be
will be exposed the controlling
community spread
broadly is not the only way of managing
the damage from this epidemic
we have to think more creatively than we
have professor
gianta batacharya from the university of
stanford in california i know it's early
where you
are so we're particularly grateful that
you joined us today
on spectator tv thank you very much
let's go straight to the big political
news of the day here in the united
kingdom jeremy
corbyn has been suspended from the
labour party the whip withdrawn from him
in the aftermath of the publication of
the human rights investigation
into anti-semitism in the labour party
uh under his watch when he was leader
james let's go straight to you give us
your reaction to this
well i think this is a sign that
kierstama knows but he needs to show
voters that this isn't jeremy corbyn's
labour party anymore
but it is under new management it is
hard to think of a more dramatic action
he could have taken than this to show
voters
that he is trying to change the party
and change its culture
it does exacerbate
uh i mean the left was already unhappy
with kyo stamina as leader in the
direction
he was taking labour in they would say
that he never really indicated this when
he stood for the labor leadership he's
kind of said he would keep the corbin
manifesto from 2019 this is going to
infuriate them now
kirsten is choosing to take on the left
very directly on this question
it is obviously on ant semitism given
what is in this report
given how frequently the report reveals
that the leader's office interfered in
these investigations he's obviously on
fairly strong ground i also think
one of the things that is emboldening
kiyostama is this the polls
at the moment fairly regularly show him
ahead on the question of who would make
the best prime minister
while labour is either level or a little
bit behind the tories i think there is a
feeling that the starmer brand right now
is stronger than the labour brand and
the labour brand is still being toxified
by its association with the corbin era
and so this is a politically necessary
move as well
i mean i i think the reaction of the
tourism will be
it is another sign of stoma's
seriousness about power
it is interesting katie i know you've
been following this too
that uh mr corbin came out with a
statement today even before the report
was published saying that it all been
dramatically overstated
because it had happened overstated by
his opponents outside the labour party
inside the labour party and in the media
mr kirsten said that you think this was
unrelated to what mr corbin had said
if you think it's all exaggerated you
should be nowhere near the labour party
so in a sense he was uh implementing
that logic
yes i think as soon as you saw jeremy
corbyn's statement
and then you heard what kierstama said
which is effectively saying
if you're not willing to say this is a
big problem then there's not a place for
you
um i think everyone started to add the
two statements up and you saw in
kierstama's
press conference that he gave after the
publication repeated questions
not so much about does he accept the
report's findings because he said he did
but how he was going to do this in terms
of his actions and what was meant for
jeremy corbyn
now kirsten in that press conference
kept batting off questions about jeremy
corbyn's future
but he had the cover that he suggested
he hadn't really read all of jeremy
corbyn's statement
uh now that it seems that he has i think
kazama
clearly concluded that they could not
really uh keep both things in existence
and
him still be able to say he should be
judged by his actions and i think that
kistama really ended that press
conference saying that
he knew he would be judged by his
actions gives us some explanation as to
why he took such a bold move
but as you touch on um this is uh not
without risk for kirstjammer and while
there is cover
even before this report's released we
were seeing corbin's allies try and put
their side of the story out
and i think he is going to face a big
backlash from the left of the party
because the left the carbonite left
is still powerful mr kierstarm is the
man in charge now
under new management he said but the
carbon easter left
is still powerful than the labour party
isn't it
yes and you've got to remember in terms
of labor policy
this goes to the membership it happens
at you know labour conferences
and the membership uh i think it's fair
to say um
have been shown time and time again to
question some of these issues
i don't think it is a wholesale
conclusion that the membership will be
completely in keeping on mass with what
kierstama is deciding so
there's still a strong uh corbin
contingent in the party
obviously not strong enough for corbin's
successor
in the form of rebecca long bailey but
strong enough when you're looking at
you know nec elections things like that
there to be corbyn candidates
uh you know of of that sense side of the
party who you expect to do well so i
this is not over all right it's over for
us for the moment we're going to move on
president macron announced a new
lockdown in france
last night bar for schools are
continuing to operate it's
pretty much as tough as the original
lockdown back in march and april
the country came to terms with that as
it did overnight there was yet another
islamist terrorist attack this time in
nice
where a jihadist armed with a knife
killed two women
and a man inside a catholic church one
of the women
was beheaded the attack comes only 10
days after a school teacher
was beheaded in paris also in southern
france today
a suspect with what was originally
thought to be a knife but turned out to
be a gun
reportedly shouting alua akbar was shot
dead
during an attack on police officers in
avignon
these are grim times indeed for france
and we're joined
by jonathan miller the spectators
correspondent in
france uh jonathan uh thank you for
joining us
i guess when you look at what happened
in paris
a teacher in france's secular teaching
system that is very proud of
the catholic church in nice uh
a woman beheaded in the church in the
catholic church along the dominant
church
in france the symbolism couldn't be
stronger
i find myself today looking
at a france that has something
fundamental seems to have changed
there's a uh a deep morosity
a depression almost about the situation
the lockdown was was really tough for
people
uh especially those living in not very
privileged circumstances
and then it was lifted and now it's been
reimposed
and macron who was so confident that he
could master this as he
has mastered he thinks so many other
problems has had to admit that it didn't
work after all and
yet within hours of this new blow of
reimposing the confinement on france we
have this uh
resumption of what seems to become a
kind of continual
low grade i don't to be
overly dramatic about this but this
there's almost the kind of
low-grade civil war going on in france
there's a bunch of people who simply do
not sign
up to the french republic as side
ideas of liberte
macron calls them islamic separatists
none of the french government's policies
before and during
and seem to have worked and
it's a deeply depressing situation where
you have first the school teacher
and school teachers in france occupy a
very
special position as symbols of
the republic of this idea of
of of an indivisible republic
where no religion is recognized yet all
are permitted and um
and uh now
reports that two of these women were
either decapitated or an attempt was
made to decapitate them
and it i think is plunging people into
a real depression it's hard to see
where this goes and you know francis
suffered a lot more than britain on
these terrorist
attacks he's had major ones like the
bataclan
and lower level ones like this no less
uh horrific
now i mean for most french i mean the
big attacks that are organized sometimes
the security services can
uh can intercept them they they take a
long while to organize at the moment
in france when you see this happening
you could be walking down any street and
not know what's going to happen to you
next
it's a it's a scary time in the country
well certainly in in villages like my
own
uh people are still very relaxed um
they're very disturbed by what's
happening but there are
these really at least two francis
there's the france perform that we all
know and we all love and the people
are kind and there's this other france
where people
are just not signed up to the program
and uh
and the efforts of the french state to
include
people have really i think you can say
have failed
i don't know if it's uh in this terribly
terribly sad
time it's too soon to start wondering if
there are actual
serious political consequences with
significant strategic changes of
direction
in store for france uh until a few
months ago i thought uh monsieur mr
macron despite the fact that he's not
loved
was at least uh had a pretty clear shot
at being re-elected
due to the this strange geometry of the
french two-round system where you vote
for the first round
in the first round for who you like and
you vote in the second round against
the person you dislike the least and i
thought he would always come on top
of marine le pen the uh the candidate of
the
rason blumen nacional formerly the
national front
i thought the french just would never
vote for le pen but more and more people
that i talk to
tell me that that assumption is uh is
not to be taken for granted
and i do wonder whether there could be a
change
in uh in people's sentiment and whether
macron is now really actually vulnerable
it's clear that mr macron himself sees
the threat to him from the right not
from the left
because even before these atrocities in
paris and now
nice he gave this speech about islamic
separatism inside france and how he
would not allow it to happen
that he was going to close down the
extremist mosques he was going to do
something
about those muslim kids who are being
educated purely in the community
outside france's secular state school
system so he senses something he seems
to me jonathan he's sensing you
he made a speech we then had this uh
this incident where the
school uh teacher was was murdered
he very strongly uh expressed solidarity
there are now
demonstrations against macron right
across the islamic world there were
photographs of a huge
demonstration in bangladesh the other
day they don't seem to get
quite as excited about the chinese uh
locking up an entire muslim community
and concentration camps
they're very excited uh about this uh
about the french the
france seems to become uh the bound an
enemy
of uh of certain islamists and uh
and macron is exposed as being actually
pretty helpless
jonathan miller in the south of france
thank you for joining us
explaining the grim times uh in france
at the moment
with these uh low-level but horrific and
deadly terrorist attacks
now free school meals for poor kids
during holidays has haunted the
government for
months now you turned in favor in the
summer it's widely expected to execute
another u-turn before christmas
leading many tory mps to wonder aloud
how the government has
walked into the same tree twice james
where are we is there a u-turn do we
begin to see it developing
so i mean there is a realization that
having this issue come back at christmas
be kind of hugely problematic for the
government one cabinet minister was
worrying to me this week that they would
look like scrooge
denying tiny tim food over the christmas
holidays so i expect come the
comprehensive spending review on
november 25th
you'll have some announcement of extra
money for some kind of holiday or
homework clubs
that will include a food element here
and i think one of the things worth
understanding is
why the government got into this mess in
the first place
and i think it is because they are very
wary at the moment about
anything that is a permanent extension
of the state
and i think they thought that announcing
of free school meals continuing during
the school holidays
would quickly become that and i think
they hope that with schools back now
school was able to alert local
authorities to which children needed the
most help
they would be able to to avoid having to
commit to doing that again
i think it is a sign though of how this
virus has changed politics
in terms of the interventions in the
economy and the restrictions on liberty
this has been like a kind of war of
national survival and you know world war
one and world war ii created the modern
welfare state and then i think the
second thing is
people i think a large number of people
are very worried about losing their jobs
because of this crisis
and so i think people have more concern
about the safe the social safety net and
how generous the welfare system
is than they normally would and you add
to that
the fact that marcus rashford the
footballer who's been leading this
campaign
is the opposite of most celebrity
activists you know we're used to
celebrities saying
let's deal with global warming then
flying somewhere by private jet
this comes from marcus rashford's lived
experience you know he was on free
school meals as a kid
you know he puts his money where his
mouth is he donates he helps out
and he's also kind of we've got used to
football as being kind of quite
bling-tastic
um he is very different from that in
style and temperament and i think that
is what makes him such a kind of
effective advocate for this cause
let me come to uh kate andrews uh
our economics editor kate is there a lot
of money involved in this
uh to to provide free school meals to
poorer kids over the holidays
we're talking tens of millions of pounds
which is a drop in the ocean compared to
what's been spent on
the kovac crisis so far uh the deficit
this year is now estimated potentially
to be over 400 billion pounds
so i think that makes the tories case
more difficult why are you
denying a few million quid possibly tens
of millions of pounds
when you're spending so much money
elsewhere but as james notes
the real concern from the treasury's
perspective here is that this once you
agree to bringing in free school meals
indefinitely that is something that you
have to account for in public spending
for
years to come the hope so far has been
that this coveted spending is a one-off
that this is a one year where you have
an extremely high deficit but then we
try to get back to normal
relatively soon and what they're very
concerned about is creating that
structural deficit
where all of a sudden you've committed
to spending that is a bit coveted
related but in the future isn't covert
related and you have to account for that
money
and that's where talk of tax rises and
austerity come back in
now we're already having those talks but
for one crisis the question is
where would the government be wanting to
spend its money how would it be wanting
to reform
welfare i mean this also brings into
conversation whether or not you should
have a voucher style program or cash
top-up there's a lot of public policy
here
and it's being decided very quickly
because of the politics around the kovak
crisis
but the treasury knows that eventually
it has to be paid for and the question
is how and
they're not prepared to answer that
we're now going to have a one-year
spending review next month
as opposed to looking years down the
line and they don't want any more
questions
that we don't have answers to if they
can help it katie is the nobody
in downing street katie balls
paid to look out for bear traps
particularly bear traps you've already
fallen into i mean the government fell
into this bear trap in the summer it
paid to get itself out
you need to be a rocket scientist to
know that there's an
october recess for schools and hey
christmas holidays as well
and yet it seemed just to stumble into
the same bear trap
i mean i think there are people paid to
do that the question is uh should they
be uh giving their money back
ultimately when you're looking at the
free school meals row i think as james
touched on
the issue is there are figures in
government who did feel as though this
was worth putting their foot down on
partly because they're worried about
permanent spending moving from emergency
spending
and then also if you look at the
parliamentary party there is still and i
would say by this point
a handful i can only count on one hand
but there are tory mps
who think the government should stick
with this policy
and actually these are tory mps in the
so-called red wall
and they think actually their voters
believe that people should you know
pay pay for their own children and
actually this is becoming a bit of a
soft liberal issue
now i've spoken to more tory mps who
have
say they've had a horrible recess uh
bless them because they've been
receiving lots of post um
paper plates lots of abuse over this um
but i do think that
where i think this uh was allowed to
roll on for a bit was because
there were plenty at least in the
beginning
in fact like moving things to the state
in the long term was bad
i think what has changed is now the line
is ultimately we are still in a
coronavirus emergency period so
it isn't a good idea to do now and it
has to be changed for the next holiday
well the government has found itself on
the wrong end of public opinion on free
school meals but two
spectator columnists who normally don't
agree about anything between them come
to its defense this week
matthew paris who accepts that he's not
with the zeitgeist on the free school
meal issue
and rod little who says well rod's
joining us i'll let him make
his case himself rod why should the
government
not be providing free school meals for
poorer kids
during the holidays well there's two
reasons i think one of them is
is uh moral and and political which is
that
there shouldn't be an extension of the
state children shouldn't be as
matthew actually quoted nationalized
effectively
nor should the feeding of children be
franchised away from parents
uh and to uh and to effectively the
state but the second point is the one
which katie touched upon
and where i think quite a lot of people
have got it wrong
again for the same reasons as they often
do
which is that those people who voted uh
conservative at the last general
election particularly in the red wall
areas
my home area of tea side but in all the
very hard working working class areas
there is nothing more that they resent
than in working hard struggling barely
getting by
but always doing the right thing by
providing for their kids
by making sure they're well fed and
they're clothed properly that they go to
school
by by doing the right thing
they then see their neighbors who are
not doing the right thing getting free
state handouts
it is a massive issue and it rarely
figures
uh because it's a very difficult issue
to talk about and it becomes very
emotive
and as you were saying you know why why
staff the children of christmas it
it gets reduced to that sort of reductio
absurdium
but amongst that core who voted for the
conservatives
for the first time possibly in many
cases it really grates
any raising benefits greats uh and
this idea that more money should be
given out after we've just seen a 20
quid rise in universal credit
it really great because of course the
main problem up there
in the north in my area and also in the
northwest is low wages
it's less unemployment than low wages
interesting you saying there rod that
the the emergence of uh
the red wall going tori and therefore
taking the tory party more into the
north more into blue-collar areas as the
americans
would call them means a harder line on
welfare issues
than a tory party more dependent on the
votes of the
leafy suburbs of the home counties
absolutely
but that's absolutely true on a number
of issues i mean if you turn to
just wait till we talk about crime
that is one of those issues where uh the
the working class particularly the
elderly working class
simply have no truck whatsoever with
criminality or with idleness
and it's something which has which comes
through in each election they used to be
called in the 60s
the blue tories it's the old
conservative
hardline working class who have now
found a new home
james what do you say to that rod may be
right may be wrong but for me to say
the one thing that is clear is the
government has made no
effort to communicate its case in the
way rod just has
yeah look i i personally think that the
government had kind of
four options for how to handle this one
was to give marx rashford what he wanted
uh and provide these three school meals
during the holidays
but the second was to say look we've
given councils the money
they know who the most vulnerable
children are they can help them and the
other was to do a kind of david cameron
style big society argument when all
these people started coming forward
saying you can come to my cafe and have
a hot meal and say
look you know there is such a thing in
society it's just not the same thing as
the state
i i think in a way the art the right
answer to rod's point
is to uh link the free school meals
to an activity to doing something so if
your kid is doing
extra education the holidays you know
doing more english and maths in a
classroom environment
the state will feed them i think that
would be and make that open to
more than just uh the children of
the the children of people and benefits
make this a wider broader system
uh we desperately need to improve the
education system in this country to
raise productivity
and i think you know i think more more
holiday more homework clubs in the
holidays would be one way to do that
rod if feckless parents uh
to use the phraseology that's quite
common are
not properly feeding their kids
who does feed them well yes a perfectly
good question
but yeah and yes of course there has to
be a safety net for those
uh who are not getting fed properly but
it's
it's kind of a sticking plaster isn't it
because what you really need to do
we have moved so far away over the last
30 to 40 years
of uh having a sense of parental
responsibility for our children
uh we we now accept
uh that the state will step in and help
us
no matter how feckless irresponsible no
matter how obese we are
you know you will get state help now if
you eat too much
um and so what you need to do in the end
yes possibly possibly and i accept
james's point that
quite possibly uh the government is
going to have to give it on this and my
guess is it
it it will because bn pennsaunt opinion
is
uh very much in favor of giving these
free school meals these vouchers to the
kids
but you have to go back you have to go
back further and examine
where personal responsibility lies and
where it stops
and teach people how to be better
parents and tell them that that is their
lookout that they have to do it that
that is the thing that they are there
for
and you know we have had 40 years of not
telling people that
kate what's your take on this i think
the cubic crisis has
taken away this idea of trade-offs which
are
so vital when we're talking about public
policy
rod has made the case against free
school meals one could make the case in
favor of extending the scheme but you
would think that they should do so
taking the cost of it into account
taking the resources
of it into account so the question would
go something like well if you want to
extend free school meals and they're
perfectly legitimate reasons for wanting
to do that
what are you going to spend less on what
aren't we going to do
as a society to make sure that we can
extend this scheme and those
conversations have gone out the window
and that is what happens when you act as
though you have discovered a magic money
tree now i don't think it's the treasury
necessarily that's acting that way i
think
um if anything people in the treasury
are the most aware that this can't go on
forever but unfortunately
because of the way that publicly we've
just evaded any discussion of what this
kova crisis is going to cost
we have completely forgotten that
everything has a price tag and that is
going to be
a hard cold reality that starts to come
back in
um probably as early as 2021 but i
suspect the real pain will come in the
years after that
when the bank of england the treasury
can't be as generous with their schemes
anymore and people are going
to be asked to pay for this either
through raising taxes ideally through
growing our society again but
frankly that's not going to happen when
we're putting into when we're put into
tier 3
plus lockdowns time and time again or
potentially through austerity again
these are tough conversations and
we're just not having them rod final
question while we've got you here are
you surprised
uh i know you welcome it i would suspect
but are you surprised that kyo starmer
has
suspended jeremy corbyn from the labour
party
um quite surprised i'd be more
interested to see what happens
to uh xiaomi chakrabarty if i'm
absolutely honest because of course
she was the one who was commissioned
on day one she was commissioned to hold
an independent inquiry into
uh anti-semitism in the labour party on
day two
uh she joined the labour party and on
day three
she cleared the labour party and on day
four she was shadow attorney general
which is a remarkable uh remarkable
occurrence
uh i i think that this is far less of a
problem
for jeff for uh kia stammer than i i
think
uh katie katie does uh or perhaps you do
uh i think that the kirsten at the
moment is in the same position as tony
blair was
a little bit in 1994-1995
he is looking to pick a fight and
it will not do him any harm to have that
fight because there is no doubt
whatsoever that the
the public did not like corbyn for a
whole host of reasons
uh and it is suspicious of momentum
on its woke agenda and also on its
foreign policy agenda
uh and it it does in no harm whatsoever
to uh to publicly be embroiled in that
fight
much as he did when he uh defenestrated
half the corporations from the cabinet
all right rod we'll leave it there
thanks for joining us on spectator tv
it's been great to have you come back
and see us
and uh talk again to us uh it's
t-minus five days until election day in
america
freddie gray the editor of the
spectators american edition both in
print
and online is in the united states for
these final days he joins me now from
bethlehem in pennsylvania one of the
battleground states in fact some would
say
it is the battleground state of all of
them uh
freddie welcome relatively early where
you are i know at the moment
just give us a general impression first
of all of where you think we are
in the campaign with five days to go
well i'd say uh trump is a tremendous
finisher i think whatever you think of
him you have to acknowledge
uh that he is a phenomenal campaigner he
has an extraordinary amount of energy
for a 74 year old man he's flying
all over the country um doing these
rallies
and there is certainly a lot of anxiety
amongst let's call them
the the sort of main media the the
democratic media
that he is going to do something
extraordinary and turn around
this massive pole deficit he's facing
and
in the key states and i'm in
pennsylvania at the moment which i think
as you say is perhaps
the key state at the moment um things
are just very odd the polls still
suggest biden's ahead
um but actually where i am at the moment
is is in bethlehem it's in quite an
affluent part of bethlehem
pennsylvania there are some biden signs
but i've been around pennsylvania quite
a lot in the last few days and it's
trump trump trump everywhere so it's
very hard to square
these polls with what you just see with
your own eyes and there was
there was a column in the new york times
this week too written by
a young man new york times reporter he
comes from
pennsylvania not from one of the big
cities but from more
rural areas and it was interesting he
was saying that
too he was saying that on the ground he
just
doesn't see what the polls are saying
he does not see uh biden way ahead
and he doesn't see trump defeated yes
well i i read that piece i thought it
was excellent and i agree you know you
go into a cafe here and the waitress
says do you think he's going to do it
and she's talking about trump
enthusiastically so it's very very odd
and i think
the real problem here is it's the
difficulties of the pandemic the panda
elections of american elections are
always very hard to read
but the pandemic makes it almost
impossible because there's one side that
is taking it far more seriously than the
other
so whereas you'll see trump people out
and about um
and particularly you'll see trump's
campaign campaign rallies
you don't see democrats and you
certainly aren't seeing a lot of joe
biden and
in 2016 the big mistake that clinton
made hillary clinton made was not
campaigning
in the key battleground states biden
seems to be repeating the same message
he is campaigning in pennsylvania
because it's close
but they're not very big rallies and
they're and they're not terribly
impressive
well you raised something that's really
struck me in the past 24 hours because
i've been reading
watching uh biden the wagon harris
ticket
they've been campaigning in georgia
campaigning in texas as well
now it would be great i can understand
what the democrats would love to get
both georgia and especially texas i mean
if they get texas it's kind of all over
i understand that
but they don't need these two states to
win
but they do need florida they need
michigan they need pennsylvania they
they
need wisconsin i would have thought
isn't this exactly the mistake hillary
clinton
made well they do i mean the democrats
have
seem to have this amazing ability for
shooting themselves in the foot
i mean arizona is another one where the
trump campaign's been doing a lot of
work in recent days
and that could be crucial if biden could
hold that then it might mean he doesn't
have to win
uh michigan or um or even pennsylvania
but i think there are other things that
suggest that the polls are
very odd i mean a poll came out
yesterday an abc news poll
suggesting that biden is 17 points ahead
in wisconsin
now everybody i know who knows about
wisconsin says that's just impossible
uh biden may well win it but 17 points
is absurd and that's a major polls to
doing that
so i think there are increasing doubts
about the reliability of the polls
and about the biden's campaign the biden
campaign's ability
to get the vote up set against that you
have to take the mail
in ballots which of course 70 million
voters have already voted
we think again we don't know there's a
lot of mystery about this
we think that gives the democrats an
advantage but
i would say if at the moment looking at
the momentum if it was on election day
i would even go out on a limb and say
trump would be the favorite to win at
the moment if it was all about election
day
but the mail-in ballot factor is huge
for the democrats
and the mail in those have already voted
will not have known because we only
learned it today that
the u.s economy grew by 7.4 percent
in the third quarter uh and the way the
americans calculate that that is
at an annual rate of 33 percent
it's a huge bounce back uh freddie
we know that mr trump wins on the
economy that is an issue
uh that has been going his way it's been
overshadowed by covert
but it's you know you look at some
things breaking at the moment
and although mr biden will surely still
be the favorite
they're kind of breaking donald trump's
way
well i spoke to a democrat who had an
interesting idea that actually a
rebounding economy is good for biden
because people relax a little bit about
the situation
and therefore they're less likely to go
i have to vote for trump because he's
the only one i trust on the economy
but i think i think overall that's
that's a sort of slightly contrarian
point
i think overall the rebounding economy
is is
very very impressive and um august good
news for trump
kate that's quite a pretty strong
figures there for the president on the
economy
yeah they are impressive uh but we
always knew that these figures were
going to come out
uh less than a week before election day
and as you've already noted
you have millions of people who've
mailed in their
ballot i think there are quite a few
things that have happened over the past
few weeks that could have
swayed hearts and minds i think donald
trump's performance in that second
debate
getting joe biden to actually put on the
record some of his public policy ideas
would have worked in favor for trump had
he allowed joe biden to speak more in
that first debate
i think you could see an even tighter
race in these swing states
and i'm inclined still to say that this
is joe biden's to
lose simply looking at the the national
polling and the swing state polling
not just now but throughout this whole
race biden has consistently been ahead
where hillary clinton was not
where donald trump and hillary clinton
were often neck and neck
but there's no doubt that trump actually
showing up in these states and
campaigning
may help him to finish in a way that is
uh better than was originally predicted
whether that's enough to get him over
the line
remains to be seen we'll find out in a
few days
freddie what can we expect in the final
five days
uh it does seem that mr trump's got his
mojo back he he loves
uh the cheering crowds that gives him
his uh
enthusiasm and his energy i assume he'll
be doing a lot more
rallies is there any move on the
democrat side to
kind of bring mr biden out a bit more in
front of the public
well we keep hearing it but he keeps his
schedule um
notifications very short so we don't
quite know we know he can do another in
pennsylvania on sunday uh
but it's all very last minute and the
crowds are small for that reason
and it's all very coveted secure so it's
hard to get a sense
of how he'll be able to roll out the
machine i think we'll see a bit more of
obama
um in the coming days but again that
does obama help biden at the moment it's
not quite clear
so i would anticipate trump everywhere
um and
the network's trying to show a bit less
and less of him because
they're getting quite worried is the net
worth being worried is interesting is
there
is there any sign that the democrats are
getting a bit
worried or because they did think they
had it in the bag and who could blame
them for thinking that a few weeks ago
particularly
when the the west wing became the
epicenter
of the epidemic is is there any
indication that the democrats are
beginning to
wake up in the middle of the night and
think this could be another 2016.
well i think so and that it's it's like
a sort of horror movie unfolding for
some of them i mean
quite bad riots in uh pennsylvania
uh in philadelphia two nights ago and uh
i spoke to a democratic strategist he
was like why
why is it just always in the swing
states you know
just the things that won't help them uh
tend to
tend to happen and again the riots cut
both ways because people might say this
is what
trump has turned america into et cetera
but also trump is in theory if not in
practice the law and order candidate
and so a serious urban unrest is
not good news for the democrats and
these are riots in another major
democratic city
uh in west uh west when west
philadelphia
uh it's in pennsylvania and
mr biden's remarks about fracking can be
used to frighten the western counties of
pennsylvania where there's a
lot of jobs dependent on fracking
rightly or wrongly you would have to say
that in pennsylvania although mr biden's
still ahead in the post
things have gone mr trump's way in this
most swing of swing states in the past
couple of days
well biden did say the other day maybe
i'm just a lousy candidate and i think
i think we have to agree that he is
although that said
button's ability to say honest things
like that is exactly what
people like about him and so that is his
likability particularly compared to
clinton
um is what will win it for him if indeed
he does win
right we will leave it there freddie
it's going to be an exciting five days
maybe more of a race
uh for the white house and it would have
looked even a couple of years ago and of
course
if it's more of a race for the white
house then
it's also going to be more of a race for
the senate if joe biden wins big
then he will take the senate with him
and the the democratic party will take
control
of all of the three major arms including
the supreme court
of the american government they'll
control the white house
they'll already control the house and
they would take the senate but if it's
closer
even if mr trump was to lose it would
not follow that the
the democrats would then take the senate
which is currently under
uh republican control we have five days
before we'll start to find out i say
start to find out
because if it is close it isn't clear
if an election day will actually know
who's won it may take several days
in fact i saw secretary of state in
pennsylvania saying
it could take up to a week so it could
be a long count
anyway thanks for joining the week in 60
minutes remember to subscribe to the
spectator by going to spectator dot co
dot uk president that's spectator dot co
dot uk slash president and you can pick
who you think is gonna win
and be the next president and if you win
if you're the right one and you've got a
50 50 chance so it can't be that bad
as well as subscribing to the spectator
you will get a 30 pound
amazon voucher that can be no better
offer than that in publishing today
thanks to all of our guests for being
with us today we covered a lot of ground
and once again thanks to our very
special sponsor
charles stanley charles stanley is one
of the uk's leading
wealth management firms and one of the
oldest firms
on the london stock exchange if you've
got any thoughts about what you've seen
keep them polite
but there is no spectator tv spectator
dot co dot uk that spectator tv at
spectator dot co dot uk
and we hope you'll join us again next
thursday
for another the week in 60 minutes
bye bye
you